hello strangeloop
so I often give talks about things that
I'm excited about
um or that I think are really fun but
today I want to talk about something
that I'm a little bit mad about
um which is that sometimes things that
seem like they should be basic take me
like 10 years or 20 years to learn like
way longer than they seem like they
should
um so one thing that took me a long time
to learn was DNS which is this question
of well like what's the IP address for a
domain name like example.com and this
feels like it should be a
straightforward thing but seven years
into learning DNS I would be setting up
a website and then you know I would feel
like things should be working and I
thought I understood DNS and then I
would run into problems like my domain
name wouldn't work and I'd be like why
not I don't get it why why don't I
understand this yet what's happening
uh and sometimes this would feel kind of
like a personal issue right
um like this shouldn't be so hard for me
I should understand this already it's
been seven years right like what's
what's going on
and sometimes if I talked about my
problems on the internet people internet
strangers would tell me like yeah you
know the problem is with you you should
understand this already
um but but luckily uh I I have kind of a
big ego and so I didn't take it too
personally and I also have a lot of
patience uh So eventually they're
probably like maybe four different
problems I was having with DNS and
eventually I figured out what all those
four different problems were and then I
got you a place where I felt like I
succeeded and I was like okay hooray
incredible I get DNS we're good
um but then later on I would see my
friends struggling with the exact same
kind of problems that I was running into
right like they'd be like hey like why
is my domain resolving and
and it doesn't end right we're still
having the same problems over and over
and over again and it's a little it's a
little frustrating
um it feels a little redundant
um and and it makes me mad especially
when my friends take it personally and
they're like hey like I should really
understand this already and I'm like no
man like everyone is going through this
this is happening to all of us
um I think it's happened with DNS to a
lot of you
um
and so I I got so mad about this that I
decided to make it my job
um I I started a little publishing
company called wizard zines uh where
[Applause]
um
wow uh where where I write about some
some of these topics and try to try to
demystify them
um here here are here are a few of them
um and I want to talk today about about
a few of these doctors and sort of like
what I've learned about
um explaining them and trying to what
what makes them so hard and how we make
them easier
um so we're going to talk about bash
we're going to talk about hdp we're
going to talk about SQL and we're going
to talk about DNS
um and for each of them we're going to
talk a little bit about a like what's
you know like what's so hard about it
and also what what what are some things
we can do to make it a little bit easier
for each other
so I want to start out with Bash
uh
and I think I think if we think about
what's hard about bash it usually uh so
Vash is a programming language right
but it's uh one of the weirdest
programming languages I think that that
I deal with
um and to talk about why it's weird
let's do like a little little little
small demo
um of of of of bash
um so I have this little script called
uh bad.sh
um oh okay let's make this a lot bigger
okay now it's a lot bigger and this just
moves a file and then Echoes success and
in most programming languages that I use
if there's a problem the program will
stop
and I think I think a lot of you know uh
from maybe a sad experience that Vash
does not stop
right it keeps going
and going
on sometimes very bad things happen to
your computer in the process
um so
um one thing I eventually learned is
that you can write this thing at the top
of your program
um we're going to look at better.sh
which is set Dash e
and what saidashi does is it says hey if
there's a problem you should stop
right
which like honestly that's what I wanted
in the first place but sure you know
we'll take it um and so if you've run
this you just see the error from envy
and then it stops
so great we're happy you know everything
is good
um wrong way over here
um but like what I've learned about that
is that every time I think I've learned
you know everything that can happen and
everything that can go wrong that should
be like oh surprise
there's a little there's more things
right there's more things that can
happen so we're going to look at another
program called Bad again.sh
where instead we put our code in a
function right and then maybe if our
function fails we want to Echo like oh
the function failed
um and we do set Dashi right so it
should be everything should be okay
um
but if we run it
we get the success message again and
didn't stop it just kept going
and this um so so this is because like
when you have this or here uh it this
disables globally so it's actually in
the function which is not not what
certainly not what I wanted right
and not not what I've expected this is
not not a bug in bash this is the
documented behavior
um
you know so this is this is what we have
um so that that that's fine
um
and I think that the thing here that
makes it tricky is a lot of us don't use
bash very often right like I maybe write
a bash script like every six months then
I'd put it there and then I don't look
at it again and just leave it
um it does its thing
and I think when you have a system that
used very infrequently and it's full of
like a lot of weird trivia and gotchas
makes it very hard to use system right
makes it very hard to use it correctly
um so like how can we how can we make it
easier right like what what can we do
about it
um and one one thing that I sometimes
hear uh is you know like this seems hard
people like oh yeah it's impossible to
use bash right no one can use Bash
um but like this is I would say like
factually untrue
um I I would like to like how many of
you are using bash like
exactly right like we're using it it's
happening
um
uh it doesn't always you know work
perfectly but like largely we have a lot
of batch programs that are mostly
working right there's like a big
community of us who are using bash
mostly successfully
um
and the way you can think about it is
you have some people on the left who are
like I don't know what is this bash it
seems awful and other people are like
okay I know I know how to make the bash
do the things for me mostly and it
mostly works
[Music]
um okay so how do we how do we like move
people from the left to the right right
like what what are we doing
um so in bash
um one thing you have is yeah there's a
giant I'm sure we have to remember
um
uh but uh who who's gonna remembering
giant fossil trivia right
um not me
but but computers computers are right
um and and for Vash uh we we have this
incredible tool called shell check
uh yeah
um until check a nose a lot of the
trivia and can just tell you like oh no
you don't want to do that
that that's gonna that's gonna give you
a bad day
um and I'm very grateful for Shell check
and it makes it much easier for me to
write my uh my tiny bash scripts which I
write from time to time
uh so oh yeah we're gonna do a little
demo of shell check on on our little
program so if we can do a shell check
and then she'll check if this is a
lovely error message you know it's a
little weird
um like
you still need to kind of like
understand that this is true and it's a
little bit hard but but still check
tells you like this is a problem that
you're having maybe you should be
worried about that and this is good in
disable set Dash e and I just think it's
so wonderful that that all these tips
live in this winter
um
uh the I think the trick here is not to
write letters
um I actually I mean I I think that some
of you probably will write lenders
because this is that kind of crowd but I
am not writing linters
um I had said the way that I write
letters is I just tell people about
shell check and then I feel like it's
like as if I invented shell check right
because the person didn't know about it
until I told them about it
um and I think I think an incredible
thing we can do
um is to kind of like reflect on like
the tools that we're using um to like
reduce our cognitive load and all the
things that we can't fit into our minds
and just make sure people know about
them right like I didn't find out about
shell check for a long time and I was
kind of mad about it when I found out I
was like excuse me like I could have
been using shell check this whole time
I did need to remember all of the stuff
in my brain oh that seems a little
unfair
um
I think telling people about these tools
makes it makes a big difference
um the other thing that that I like to
do is to warn people
about about gotchas and some of the
Terrible Things computers have done to
me
um
I think this is an incredibly valuable
community service
um the the the thing that I shared about
how to disabled something I learned from
a friend just a few weeks ago um they
were like this thing happened to me at
work and it was very upsetic and I I was
like wow that is very upsetting
and now I know and I don't have to go
through that myself personally you know
um I guess uh honestly I think probably
the lesson I'm going to learn from that
is to limit my use of functions I have
to keep my bash script simple but um
yeah
it's incredible and and one way I I see
people trying to kind of trying to share
things terrible things that their
computers have done to them is by
sharing like best practices
um but what I always love is I always
love to hear like the story this is like
um like every time someone has like a
strong opinion they were like no one
should ever use that she'll like tell me
what what happened what did batch do to
you I need to know
um and I think I think the incredible
thing about Stories versus best
practices is if I know the stories of
how how the computers have hurt you
um that I can take that take that
information and decide for myself how I
want to proceed right like maybe I'm
like oh
the computer did that to you that's okay
I I could deal with that
I don't mind
or sometimes I'll be like oh no
um I'm gonna do the thing you
recommended because I do not want that
to happen to me
but sometimes yeah sometimes I don't
mind so I want to know I want to know
what I'm getting into
um so that was Bash
next up we're going to talk about hdp
um so when
I I was talking uh to Marco Rogers at
some point many years ago and he said uh
like new developers are struggling with
HTTP and at first I was a little
confused about this I was like what's um
heard about hdb and because the way I
was thinking about it at the time was
kind of like you know if you have an
interviewer spots it has a few parts it
has this response code
um it has some headers it has a body
and I thought okay like that feels like
a relatively simple structure right
so like what's what's the problem so so
I talked to a friend about uh who was
confused about HTTP who was new to it
and they asked well why does it matter
what headers you said
and I was like well you know the browser
and then I thought at the browser
I thought browser that browser
[Laughter]
is that like Firefox is 21 million lines
of code right
um and like we we have like it's been
evolving since the 90s
um there have been I think as I
understand it one million changes to
like the browser security model over the
years as we've just people have
discovered new and exciting exploits
um and as the whole life became scarier
and scarier place
um the browsers really a lot to
understand
um and then like once I thought about
that I was like well of course people
are a bit confused about http
right if you have to understand what the
browser is doing
um so then suddenly it went from like
okay this is simple it's like wait how
do I talk about this at all
um so like you know oh yeah the trick
for knowing
why things are hard
is if there's 20 million lines of code
somewhere like maybe that's why maybe
that's why people are confused
um but then like okay how do we how do
we how do we make it easier
um and how do we how do we wrap our
minds around this like 20 million lines
of code right
um and so one thing I think about is
like okay these are some of the Issue
request headers
that's like kind of a big list it's like
43 headers there
um there's some more like optional ones
people use
like this assumes like kind of
overwhelming in a lot
um but like I um have a small brain
it's not that big it does not contain
all those that information many of those
things I have no idea what they are
um and so uh when when I think about
trying to try to explain things
um and try to explain like how do you
fit like the information about these 20
million lines of code into your brain
I'm like well what is actually in my
brain right
um which only contains you know a human
normal human number of things
um so this is something I drew about
HTTP and you don't need to read this
whole thing but I want to talk about
kind of the shape of it
um so this has 15 headers
um these are the ones that I would say
that I know about and that I've used I
wrote the most important request headers
what I mean by most important is these
are the ones that I used
that I
it's a very very subjective view which I
think in general is my policy
I like to talk about a little like
here's what I know about that's a
starting point you could try
um Opening 12 words about each one which
I think is approximately the amount of
information about each one that lives in
my mind right
um like I know that you can set the
except according to gzip and that's all
you know that's all I know ah
um and that's often all I need to know
right like this this set of very small
set of information is working pretty
well for me
um the the general way I think about
this trick
um is like the it's this is like turn a
big list into a small list this is like
the set of all the things and she's like
here's the ones that I've used and that
I know that
um
and uh I think I think that this helps a
lot
um another example of those like big
list smallest thing is uh command line
arguments um so I use a lot of command
line tools and like if you look at the
man page for a command line tool it's
like this is these are the flags of the
man page for prep I said oh
that's too much
I'm like a very I've been using graph
for 20 years you know but like I don't
know what all that stuff is you know
like when I look at the Grab map page
this is what I see right
[Applause]
um I think it's it's really valuable
when people are starting out to be like
well look as someone who's been using
the system for a while I know about
seven things about it
and here's what they are
um and just like pinning those like
pruning those lists down to like a more
like human scale
um I think I think I think is really
helpful
and then like okay but like what about
the stuff that doesn't fit in my brain
right because like I have you know a few
things about HTTP in my brain but then
when I'm when I'm using it sometimes I
need to I need I need other information
which has been like swapped out right
um like maybe the details about how
course Works uh
um and so that's where we come to
references right like where where are we
looking at the information
um and references are another one of
these things like tools that like I
often find kind of hard to find
um I've been trying to learn CSS on and
off for 20 years I've made a lot of
progress It's been going well
um but only very recently I learned
about this wonderful website called CSS
tricks which is very good and has a lot
of information and I was like why didn't
I know about this before
would have helped to me
right until like someone mentioned
they're like oh yeah use CSS tricks and
I was like what what
come on
but anyway I'm very happy to know about
it now even though I'm
some things have happened to it I'm
still happy to know about it
um and the older posts
um for HTTP I think a lot of us use the
Mozilla developer Network
um another yeah
I love the the cheer little cheer from
mdn
um another another HTTP reference I
really love
um is the official RFC there's like a
new uh like uh like description of how
HTTP works that's authoritative and it
was written just last year and they were
like hey let's just write this all down
really nicely
um so if you want to know exactly like
what the connection header does you can
look it up and I just really appreciate
that people did that
um this is not I would say this is not
my top reference I'm usually more on MDM
but I love knowing that this is there
um in case I've ever like get an HTTP
argument with someone I don't know it
doesn't it doesn't happen
but if it did I would know where to go
to decide to decide who's right
um
so I love to share my favorite
references
um I do I do sometimes find it tempting
to kind of lie about references like not
on purpose but like I'll get really
excited about like something I saw on
the internet I'm like oh yeah you can
use this and then my friend will be like
oh but like when do you use that like
when have you used that I was like oh
yeah I never used it I just thought it
was cool
just thought it seems cool
um and so it's important to me to try to
try to be like a little intellectually
obvious honest about like what are the
references that I'm actually using
um in real life um even if maybe they're
like a little embarrassing like
uh or I'm like oh yeah I I sometimes I
visit like it's like I don't even know
what embarrassing references I use but I
know there are some
um
anyway
um that's that's http
um next up we're going to talk about SQL
um
the case of the mysterious execution
order
uh so
I I sort of think about SQL because
someone mentioned that they're trying to
learn SQL the way I get most of my ideas
is one person will say something and
I'll be like oh yeah okay I'm now gonna
spend six months on that
um it's a weird process
um and and then I I was wondering like
um okay like what's what's hard about
SQL
um what what gets in the way of trying
to learn that
um and this I want to say that like when
I'm confused about what's hard about
something that's always a fact about me
right like I'm like wait and something
that like I need to work on to
understand like why this thing is hard
um because it's it's so easy to forget
um when you've been using something for
a while
what
oh something has gone wrong
it's exciting
let's see what happens
oh
oh we're back incredible
incredible let's go back to the
slideshow View
okay amazing computers
um
okay yeah so I was wondering what's hard
about SQL because I was very used to
reading these queries right like this is
a query that tries to find people who
own exactly two cats for some reason
um I was like okay sure you know select
from where group I haven't ordered by
but then again I was talking talking to
a friend about it who was new to SQL
they were like well but what's that
doing
I was like hmm Fair Point
and I think the point my friend was
making
um was that the order that this code is
written in is not the order that it
happens in right it happens in a
different order
um
and one one question I really like to
think about
um in cases like this is like well like
oh yeah how do we make it easier
um what does the computer do first right
like what actually happens on the first
chronologically right like computers do
live in the same timeline as us
um things happen
things happen in order uh so like what
what happens first
um and so like in in an SQL query in
this case I should build a query
um the way I think about it is like you
have like a table right like cats
um then maybe you filter it you remove
some stuff
um then you make some groups
um then you filter the groups
then you do some aggregation so you're
like there's two things in each group
um and then you can sort it and you
could also uh
live it limit the results
um so that that's how I think about SQL
um and that means that you can kind of
like talk about the order that things
run in right at least conceptually I
think in real life databases have
optimizations and it's a little more
involved
um this is the mental model that I use
most of the time and it mostly works for
me um so you have like from where Group
by having and everything is kind of in
the same order as it is when you write
it except select is somehow fifth
how I think about it
um and
um I've really gotten a lot out of this
this trick of like trying to tell like
the chronological story of what of what
the computer is doing I want to talk
about a couple of other examples of this
um another one is is Coors which you
mentioned before I don't really uh I
think that this comic as way too small
to read
um but the idea has written is basically
that like if you're if you're making a
cross-origin request in your browser you
can just talk about okay like what is
every message that being that's being
sent right like you have the browser and
then you have the server and what what's
what's the back and forth what's
happening and you can just go through it
step by step chronologically and I think
it makes it a lot easier a lot easier to
understand a lot more concrete
um another
and but like
answer answering this question so I
think this is a very straightforward
structure which is what I like about it
like because it's like well what happens
first it's like a very um
you know it feels like it should be easy
to answer but it's not like it's very
hard to actually know what our computers
are doing I found
um so one one one example of how this is
hard is I wrote a blog post recently um
called behind hello world on Linux that
talks about what happens when you run
hello world and I wrote it and I was
like you know cool cool cool
um I wrote a bunch of things I was
really happy with it
um and then when I was thinking about it
I was like I feel like I wrote about
this 10 years ago
so I looked at my blog and I'd written
the exact same Post 10 years ago
but this this is really cool because the
2013 version of this post
um it was really and honestly I think
I'm a more concise writer now than I am
then right the problem was that the
original post did not have a lot of
information about it because I didn't
know what has happened chronologically
on the computer right in 2013 very well
and in 2023 I know a lot more and I
think there's still honestly quite a lot
been a missing um but that's okay we're
gonna maybe in 2033 there'll be ten
thousand words
um about about what happens
chronologically on your computer when
you run hello world
um so like it's an uneasy question and I
think a lot of us
um like like me in 2013 and honestly me
now often don't know the facts right of
what's happening on the computer when
you do a thing
um it's very hard which is I think what
makes it such a fun question to try to
try to discuss
um
the the the thing I think is cool about
this is that all of us I think have
different knowledge about what is
happening chronologically in our
computers and we can all kind of like
chip in right
um like when I posted this blog post
some people were like oh
um I have a lot of thoughts about uh
what happens exactly in your uh in your
terminal uh what like like I think at
the very last stage I was like well then
you write hello world and they're like
but what about there's a whole other
world
I was like that's great uh I would love
to know about that but I do not right
um and honestly it's a little no but I
would like to learn one day
um what's in there
um I think it's just a really fun
collaborative question
um I've seen it work really well as like
an activity with co-workers um where
you're like hey there's this thing in
our company when you make this request
comes in what do we what do we do how
does that work right
um what I see a lot of some people like
oh yeah okay so what happens is you have
this and this and this and this and this
and then it goes over there
and I don't really know
what happens and then someone from the
over their team will be like oh yes when
it gets over here we do this and this
and this and this and then I don't know
um and I think it's really fun to get
together people with people who have
different specializations and and talk
about try to like make these like little
timelines
um of what of what the computer is doing
um I think it's really fun and I've
learned a lot from doing that with
people
um so now we've arrived at DMS it's kind
of where we started the talk
um and like what's hard what's hard
about DNS
um and when I started writing about this
I actually found it kind of hard because
I you know I talked about how I
struggled with DNS but then once I got
there and I was interested I was like oh
yeah okay dude this is easy
even though it just took me like 10
years to learn how it works
um and I struggled so much but of course
DNS is not you know was really hard for
me to learn it's like why is that right
like why did it take me so long
um so I have a little little chart here
of how I think about DNS
um it's a conceptualize this thing so
you have your browser and then over on
the right you have the authority of name
servers who work I like the source of
truth about all the information right
and then in the middle you have like a
function that you call and then you have
a cache in the middle so you have like
browser function Cash Source of Truth
cool
um and the pro a problem with this
um is that there are a lot of things in
here that are totally hidden from you
um the the library code that you're
using when you make a DNS request often
there are a lot of different
possibilities for what it could be and
it's not all straightforward to figure
out what it is this is like a source of
a lot of my confusion it's just that
there are different possible libraries
that could be used
um the result there's a cache which has
a bunch of cache data that is also
invisible to you and which you also
don't really have a good way to look at
and often have no control over and
there's also a conversation between the
cash and the source of Truth these like
two red arrows which also you can't see
at all
um so like that's kind of tough right
like how are you supposed to develop an
intuition for a system when it's only
doing things that are completely hidden
from you like that's a bit rude
um
um so what what what do we do about that
right
um
so one thing I was thinking about was
like well let's talk about just these
little arrows on the right right
um so we have our cache and then we have
the source of Truth and this normally is
totally hidden from you because you
don't really control either of these
servers
um and definitely they are too busy uh
doing very high performance Computing to
like report to you what they're doing
right to give you like cool debugging
information but I thought
um well like you know anyone can write
an authoritative name server in
particular I could write one
um that does whatever I want right and
that reports back everything everything
that it does
um so so with my friend Marie
um we we wrote we wrote a little DNS
server and I want to do a little demo of
it
um so this uh is called mess with DMS
um the idea is that I have a domain name
and you can do whatever you want with it
uh
uh so we can make we're gonna make a
little DNS record
called strange Loop
um we're going to point it at a another
domain I have which is just a picture of
an orange
because I like oranges and we're going
to create it and then over here
um so so every time a request comes in
from a resolver this will this will
report report back what happened so if
we click on this link we can see okay
cool some requests came in some DNS
requests and it's like oh it asks for
the ipv4 address and the IPv6 address
that's nice um this is a I think a
Canadian a Canadian DNS resolver which
is apparently what my browser is
configured to use right so I've already
learned something
um oh
oh
you guys
[Applause]
you're doing such a great job of my demo
thank you
so wonderful
um so so all of you I don't even need to
go either make other requests in my
terminals
um because
you're you're all you're all using
different DNS resolvers so some of you
are coming from using ad guard some of
you are on T-Mobile
some of you are using cloudflare 1.1.1.1
as your DNS resolver
um do we see anything else fun in here
there's a lot of cloudflare
um sometimes cloudflare request an https
record I honestly do not know what that
is or why it's doing that that's like a
fun question
um and just like uh Dave was here thank
you
[Laughter]
um
and so so we're already seeing a lot of
like what's happening behind the scenes
uh in DNS I did this in the hotel and I
was a little bit stressed because I
think what was happening in the hotel is
that the uh the hotel was intercepting
all my DNS connections and running it
through their DNS resolver which was
very cool but I wasn't didn't feel 100
uh ready to explain it
on stage so I'm very happy the DNS set
up here is a little more like what I'm
used to
um but yeah
that's uh that that's how we can show
some things that are hidden
um thank you all for participating in My
Demo
[Applause]
um all right
um another another example of showing
things that are hidden that I really
like
um is that his website called
float.exposed
um yeah I hear I hear some bands uh who
who show you how how floating Point
number works
um
and
you can do you can do a lot of fun
things here let me see if I can remember
how to do this I want to find
127 is that it no
uh this is not gonna I don't remember
exactly how to do this
there's a number
is it this one oh yeah here it is here
it is okay so so one one fun thing about
floating Point especially 32-bit
floating Point um is that you you have
like if you have the number uh 16
million and then you look at the next
floating Point number after that it's
two more
and then if you go up a little more
then the next number after that is 16
more and they just get farther and
farther apart anyway this is not a talk
about what I want I could truly do an
entire talk just in this site I'm
talking about fun things about bloating
point and how it works but that's not
this talk we need to we need to go back
um
to talk about how it's nice it's nice to
show hidden things about how the
computer works
um yeah
I think one other trick for DNS when you
have a distributed system is like maybe
you're confused because there are five
million computers involved
most of which you have no control over
and some of which are doing not what
they're supposed to do
um
so that's another trick for
understanding why things are hard
um so like what what else what else part
of a DNS right
um so we talked about how most of the
system is hidden from you
um another thing that's hard is
sometimes I think the tools are
confusing
um
so another thing that I talked about
with hidden is that the resolver has
Cash Cash data right
um and you might want to know what's in
the cache just to understand what's
happening right you're like am I getting
this result because it was cached or is
this not cash what's the deal
um so you actually can kind of query a
resolver to ask it what it has cash
um there's this uh this uh flag called
plus newer curse
um and this is maybe in a way a way of
asking like how popular is my website
like is it popular enough that you have
it saved or has no one visited it my my
records are not saved for that long
they'll only stay for like five minutes
um so I'm basically asking like Hey
Google has anyone asked for our website
in the last five minutes
um but when I look at this response this
is a little bit like oh my God like
please what is all this
um and I think that this kind of thing
can be really when I show people to the
this this one and they're not used to it
they're like oh this DNS thing must be
really complicated and I'm like no man
like this is just
maybe not the best way to format it
um so like what can we do about
um a confusing outfit right
um one of my favorite trick I call
eraser eyes
um which is I like to show people like
hey like when I look at this
um all this stuff I don't see a lot of
it right like my eyes are ignoring it
what I see is just this
I see this thing where it says serve
fail which is a very unintuitive way of
it saying I do not have that in my cash
and no one has wanted to know about your
website in the last five minutes
um
which now I know you know
um and and I think that there's I've
learned so much from people just like
doing a little demo of a tool being like
hey you know this is how I use this tool
these are the things that I look at and
these are the things I ignore which is
usually most of it right and this is
like the information I have in my brain
related to like the output format of
this tool
um
and I I really love to use to use dig
even though it's kind of a little hairy
um because it's everywhere you know and
it hasn't changed I know that if I learn
it's weird output format once then then
I can then I can know that forever
um and I really love to have that
um so what can we do about all this
we've talked about like some problems
and I want to talk about like a little
bit more about like what are we doing
um and like what are we doing to kind of
like help like move ourselves from like
we don't understand to like okay I
mostly can deal with DNS at least 90 of
the time
um and I don't feel too stressed about
it or I could deal with that or I could
deal with http
um we talked about a bunch of tools
trickstering people over um like sharing
useful tools or your references or like
trying to tell like a story of like I
think this thing happens first and then
this happens later
um we talked about uh showing hidden
things and like demoing weird tools and
trying to be like I I know what this one
means when it says this it means this
and then this other stuff I don't know
and
um sharing what we know but when when I
did some practices of this talk some of
my friends were like I don't do that
stuff Julia and I really disagreed with
them so I want to talk about that
because in my and my friends were like
well you know I don't have a Blog you
know like I'm not a blogger like usually
and I was like no man like
um I think I really think you don't need
to like like be on the internet to be an
important part of this process of like
telling people about like how you use
computers and like how you understand
them
um and my experience is that a lot of
people
um have helped me understand how
computers work and like have shared like
little pieces of their experience with
computers
um like my co-workers have learned a lot
from my friends and honestly a lot of
random strangers on the internet and I
think some of you
uh have helped me over the years
um maybe on Twitter or on Mastodon
um and I want to talk about some of the
some of the people you can maybe raise
your hand if you think that this is you
one person I think who's really helped
me is the Grumpy Old Timer I see some
hands
where I'm like wow it's so cool and
they're like yes however
[Laughter]
um here let me tell you some stories
of how this has gone wrong right
in my life
um we have the loud newbie
um who's like wait how does that work
and then everyone else is like oh thank
God like it's not just me
um I think it's especially valuable uh
when when the like loud newbie person is
actually like kind of experienced
um I sometimes try to do this when I
feel it went in a place where I'm pretty
confident and I'm like excuse me
I don't understand this um when I feel
like I'm not going to be judged I think
it's a nice thing to do when you feel
like you're not going to be judged so
that other people who feel like they
will be judged can like come along on
your coattails
um
I have the bug chronicler
who's like okay that bug
this could never happen again
I'm gonna make sure we understand what
happened because I want this to end now
um we have the tool Builder who is like
I don't know I'm not going to speak to
you about this but I can write code and
the code will fix it
um
we have the person who like today I
learned person who's like hey guys I
learned this cool new thing
um check out this weird bug
um we have the person who's read the
entire internet and has 700 tabs
um oh really I value a lot
um we have the person who's just willing
to answer questions right and it was
like yeah I can tell you how that works
you know
um and I think I feel like kind of like
at the end of all of this right I'm like
sometimes you have someone who's really
who's willing to write some things down
and who's like okay wait a second I'm
gonna write this somewhere where other
people can read it and can find it later
um but I think I think that uh this like
the documentarian really comes at the
end of the whole process and all of us
all these people kind of need to work
together right so that we can all figure
out how all this weird stuff that we use
works
um so those the those are those are all
the people
um and we're almost out of time so to to
end
I the one thing I'd like to convince you
of
um is I feel like if you're struggling
with something that feels basic like
it's not just you you know I think we're
all struggling with a lot of these
things I feel like this should be basic
um and we're struggling for things for
reasons right
um and I think for a lot of the same
reasons and uh much like much like when
debugging a computer program like if
you're if you have a bug you want to
understand why the bug is happening if
you're gonna fix it
um I think if if we're all struggling
with the same things together
um I think if we
you know I think if we um
I think we sorry
I think if we know why we can figure out
how to fix them
um so some of the reasons we talked
about was like maybe uh the the program
is a giant pile of trivia and gotcha we
talked about how maybe there's a maybe
there's 20 million lines of code
somewhere
um maybe the system is being hidden from
you uh maybe the Tool's output is
extremely confusing and no UI designer
has ever thought about in their life
um
there there's a lot of these things
going on
um
I'm gonna say like I don't have all the
answers for why things are hard
um
I I do not understand uh yet really why
why git is hard it's something I've been
thinking about recently
um but that's something that's something
I'm excited to keep working on I keep
trying to figure it out figure out
um that's all that's all I have for you
thank you
[Applause]